hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and asta from
black clover just had the worst day of
his life first his marriage proposal
gets rejected then his role model the
wizard king turns out to be a villain
who attacks him then the woman he loves
is turned into an angelic demon fallen
angel type creature right in front of
him and then she tells him to please die
as he gets sliced by lucius oh and did i
mention that julius is likely asa's
father and that his entire existence is
a lie crazy stuff i know but i will
explain it all right now you guys know
what to do if you enjoy our vids and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it only takes you
a second but it really helps us with
that youtube algorithm and if you
haven't already make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications the
way that youtube works you really have
to go through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
this you're still going to miss a ton of
our video even if you are subscribed
it's just how it goes finally this video
will contain black clover manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned the latest chapter confirms
that asta is indeed using his devil
union form against lucius but because he
can only maintain this form for 5
minutes he has learned a new technique
in order to compensate for that time
limitation over the course of the time
skip asta has learned to use a sort of
partial form of devil union in which he
limits the amount of anti-magic that he
releases and this actually increases the
time limit that he has from 5 minutes to
10 minutes osta concentrates his
anti-magic on a single point such as his
arm and sword instead of dispersing it
throughout his entire body and this
doesn't only increase his time limit but
it also allows him to deliver stronger
and more densely packed anti-magic
attacks this is a great little technical
improvement for asta and he is
definitely going to need it because
lucius does not mess around due to his
ability to manipulate time lucius's
magic makes him too fast for asta to be
able to successfully deliver a decisive
blow and with sister lily still being
right there behind us as all of this is
happening asta also has to worry about
her safety after successfully dodging
asta's attacks lucius goes on the attack
as well launching multiple time magic
spells right at his opponent lucius
proclaims that magic which manipulates
time is supposed to be invincible
because there is nothing in this world
that can defy time and yet there is only
one glaring exception to this rule and
that exception is anti-magic anti-magic
is the natural enemy of time magic
because it is immune to the effects of
magical time manipulation during the
fight lucius even manages to directly
touch hosta like he did with damnatio
kira but even that fails to have an
effect on asta now annoyed lucius
concludes that the only way to defeat
asta is through physical attacks because
magical attacks simply won't cut it even
if we're talking about the most
overpowered magic in the world as the
fight between asta and lucius rages the
buildings around them begin to collapse
from the damage and this means that once
again asta has to worry about his
friends and all the other innocent
bystanders who are happening to be there
along with fighting lucius this only
makes the already difficult task of
fighting someone like lucius even more
challenging now fully aware that he
can't rely on magical attacks lucius
decides to turn the fight into what is
essentially hand-to-hand combat now of
course this is hand-to-hand combat that
involves like flying and superhuman
strength and super speed but nonetheless
it is a close distance brawl between the
two men lucius appears impressed by the
strength and fighting ability that asta
demonstrates and he says that just as he
thought asta will surely turn out to be
a serious threat to the peace of the
world but lucius declares that as long
as he is alive he won't let asta destroy
the peaceful world that he has been
trying to create for decades he explains
that he was born into a family of devil
hosts the zogradus family but he somehow
learned to purify the power of a devil
which allowed him to unlock magic that
brings sacred power to man in that
moment we see lucius transform but
instead of attaining another devilish or
demonic looking form he suddenly attains
just the opposite lucius turns into a
shining angelic being he has six angelic
wings he has halos above his head and a
large halo behind his back he has
majestic deer antlers growing out of his
head and he has thin lines running
across his body the mark on his forehead
also changes from a dark sun to a bright
sun and he appears to be holding a new
grimoire a light-colored grimoire with
celestial designs all over it this
grimoire does look like the dark
grimoire that lucius revealed in chapter
331
and it could just be the angel
transformation version of that grimoire
but we have to note that the color is
clearly different and the two spade
symbols in the middle seem to have
morphed into something new and asta
immediately notices that something is
different about lucius's key it no
longer feels like human key or devil key
it is something different all together
and honestly this is a really
interesting development i just assumed
that as lucius transformed his
appearance would look more and more
devil-like as was the case with his
siblings but tabata just threw us a
curveball by making lucius's
transformation look like the furthest
thing from devils he looks like an angel
and judging by what he said it seems
that lucius was able to somehow purify
devil magic in order to turn it into
this strange new angelic magic a magic
that lucius believes represents the
pinnacle of humanity this is what true
humans look like osta then loses track
of lucius's teleportations and before he
can do anything to stop him lucius grabs
sister lily and begins using her as a
human shield against asta lucius then
reveals the true nature of his magic and
yes many of us have been predicting this
for a while dante has flesh or body
magic vanica has blood magic xenon has
bone magic and lucius has
soul magic
this magic has the power to transform
the soul of anyone that lucius touches
and in this case the soul seems to refer
to the entire essence of the person the
soul is the source of a human's life
mind and magic which means that lucius
can seemingly transform the appearance
the personality and the magic of anyone
he touches lucius then uses his magic on
sister lily who is transformed into an
angelic being similar to lucius himself
her personality also seems to have
changed instantly right along with her
appearance because she tells asta to
please die for the sake of world peace
as austa is distracted by this shocking
turn of events lucius uses the
opportunity to slice osta across the
chest with a physical attack
as a clearly injured asta falls to the
ground lucius bids farewell to the flaw
of the world and this insane and
heartbreaking chapter comes to an end
now we all know that asta isn't gonna
die from this injury that's not even a
question but man what is this crazy new
angelic state how was lucius able to
purify devil magic in order to turn it
into some sort of celestial or angelic
magic and why does he state that this is
the true nature of humans does this mean
that lucius plans to save the world by
turning all humans into like celestial
slaves whose personality is controlled
by him kinda like what he just did to
sister lily i did notice something about
the angelic wings on lucius while lily
seems to just have two large wings
lucius has six wings growing out of the
halo on his back this is intriguing
because in the bible there are celestial
beings with six wings and these beings
are known as the seraph the sarah for
seraph are known for singing the praises
of god but lucius didn't really mention
god or the idea that he is serving a god
or gods
so is this a hint that lucius plans to
use devil magic to turn himself into a
god and then all the humans he turns
into angels will just serve him as his
celestial slaves
if this is lucius's plan for world peace
just turning everyone into an obedient
slave then it makes sense that he wants
to destroy osta his plan relies on being
able to manipulate every single human
with his soul magic but since he can't
manipulate asta asta will surely fight
back and ruin his plans so in order for
lucius's master plan to work both osta
and ante magic have to go
now i'm wondering was it this soul magic
that gave julius the ability to
transform his appearance
or is that a separate type of
transformation magic that is unique to
julius since julius and lucius are two
souls within one body do they each have
a magic of their own or do they both
share soul magic and if they both do
have their own magic then are they still
able to use the magic of the other
person i bring this up because the more
i think about it the more i keep going
back to what i said in my previous black
clover video i don't think it's a
coincidence that asta just happens to be
born as the ultimate secret weapon for
fighting against lucius i keep thinking
that asta's birth may have been
pre-planned by julius who of course has
been aware of lucius's powers for
decades and who has been looking for a
way to defeat him ever since he first
realized just how dangerous lucius is i
believe that julius had some way of
doing his own thing in secret without
lucius realizing what he was doing and i
believe that the reason why julius
traveled so often in search of rare
magic and magical knowledge is because
he has been searching for a way to
defeat lucius i think that one day 18 or
19 years ago julius found lychita and he
became aware of her unique absorption
magic i think he realized that lychita
could one day give birth to the natural
enemy of lucius and so he fathered asta
together with lychita but how did julius
and lychita achieve this well besides
the obvious part what i mean is how did
baby asta survive inside lichita's womb
when her magic sucks the life force out
of every living creature around her
except for devils of course
well
if we assume that julius himself was
spared from her magic because he is a
devil host then how do we explain the
fact that asta also survived what if
asta is actually
astaroth hear me out what if julius used
soul magic to somehow transfer the soul
of the time devil asteroth into the body
of lychita's baby but he did it in a way
that allowed asteroth's time magic to
remain inside julius's body and only his
soul was transferred into baby asta
could this be why we still haven't seen
asteroth because the soul of asteroth or
at least some part of it is actually
within asta himself
i mean the name itself is a dead
giveaway isn't it the name asta is
literally one half of the name asteroth
the real reason why asta survived being
inside lichita's womb and the reason he
was the only human who was born without
magic is the fact that he is actually a
devil soul inside a human body his
original magic time magic remained
within julius lucius so he was born
magicless and he was able to survive the
effects of lychita's magic because
devils are not affected by it as we saw
with liebe if this crazy theory is true
then it's safe to assume that julius
wasn't fully honest with lychita because
we know that she left baby asta at the
orphanage out of fear that her magic
would accidentally drain his life force
if diasta is asteroth theory is true
then she didn't really need to worry
about this although this potential
deception would make sense from the
perspective of julius it is much easier
for him to keep an eye on asta if asta
is in an orphanage inside the clover
kingdom than if he is out in the middle
of nowhere with lychita on top of that
for this theory to work we must explain
why asta has no memories of actually
being the devil asteroth and this could
be where time magic comes in julius
could have used time magic to
essentially rewind asteroth's
personality and consciousness to the
point that it was just the consciousness
of a baby a blank slate or the fact that
he somehow removed asteroth's soul or
part of the soul from his magic could
have led to asteroth losing his memories
finally if we assume that julius really
can use soul magic then he may have
altered asteroth's soul in such a way
that he no longer remembered who he once
was in chapter 334 lucius implies that
the soul is connected to the mind and he
seems to be able to manipulate sister
lily's mind and personality so mind
manipulation could be possible in this
scenario chibi julius definitely seemed
to lose some of his memories after he
revived himself following the battle
with pottery because he seemed genuinely
surprised that he was actually a devil
host and that lucius was hiding inside
of him this may have been foreshadowing
what is about to be revealed about asta
and asteroth but if all of this is true
then why would julius someone who is
clearly good and has good intentions
potentially do all these shady things
why would he go so far as to maybe even
manipulate a nice person like lychita
and play god with the life of lychita's
baby
the answer is of course for the greater
good lucius is a threat to all of
humanity and if his plans succeed then
the world as we know it will be
destroyed
julius may have decided to engage in
manipulation and other shady tactics
because he needed to find a way to stop
lucius and the only solution was to
father a child who would become the
ultimate weapon in the fight against
lucius a child who would become lucius's
natural weakness a child born without
magic a child whose soul may be the soul
of the time devil asteroth and a child
who would eventually learn to wield
anti-magic after a fateful encounter
with the same grimoire that liba had
been trapped inside many years earlier
maybe this is why lucifero didn't
remember liebe when they finally met
again during the spade kingdom ark maybe
it wasn't actually lucifero who killed
lychita maybe was someone pretending to
be him or if it was him maybe he was
actually being manipulated into doing it
and he didn't have any memory of it
happening this might sound crazy but how
else are you going to make sure that the
flaw of nature asta will one day come
into contact with liba and anti-magic in
order to make sure that this happens you
have to create a situation in which liba
is sealed away inside a grimmar and then
you have to ensure that this very same
grimoire will one day choose asta at
just the right time in just the right
place i know this seems really dark and
twisted for black clover and i'm not
saying that this theory is definitely
gonna be confirmed but man if it did
what a twist that would be asta is
actually the devil asteroth his birth
and his fateful meeting with liebe were
all a part of one big master plan and
julius who we know as an honorable guy
with good intentions actually resorted
to some extremely shady methods maybe
even murder in order to create the
ultimate weapon for fighting against
lucius and that ultimate weapon is his
own son the flaw of nature asta alright
i am now in full conspiracy mode so i
have to call it a day let me know what
you guys think could julius be osta's
father and could osta be a human with
the soul of asteroth inside of him did
julius manipulate lychita osta and liba
in order to one day defeat lucius or is
something else going on here don't
forget to leave your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment it
helps me out a lot and if you're new to
the channel or you just haven't
subscribed yet make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
seriously if you don't go through the
trouble of subscribing then hitting the
bell and then selecting the option that
says all you're still gonna miss a ton
of our videos even if you are subscribed
that's how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at anime opera
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including alpha sigma pate heffa the
toasted chi corey mcgowan big buddhist
and jeremy pontier and i can't forget
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor fat boy games
kaido might be a duck alivania and anime
s codem if you guys enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon or
here through youtube memberships even a
single dollar helps and it means a lot
to us as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys